imagine
You are on a totally packed city bus
The doors shut the bus lurches forward and suddenly like your heart is just hammering against your ribs
Right the air feels way too thick to breathe. Your brain is literally screaming at you to get out immediately
What is actually happening there? Are you you know?
Experiencing social anxiety or are you dealing with agoraphobia and getting the answer wrong there could lead to I mean
Honestly years have completely failed therapy
Yeah, the difference between those two diagnoses isn't in what you're doing like you're avoiding the bus either way, right?
It is entirely in the hidden cognitive machinery. That's
Driving the panic welcome to the deep dive today. We are unpacking a really fascinating set of notes from an instructor named keek
It's part of a clinical exam prep program called pass ready prep
Yeah
And while you might not be sitting for a psychology licensing board anytime soon
The reason key hammers these specific conditions so hard is that people in the real world?
Constantly disastrously misunderstand them. They really do she calls this group the rest of the anxiety family
I mean we all know what generalized anxiety looks like but these are the discrete
Highly defined conditions that just get glossed over right like specific phobia or agoraphobia
Separation anxiety and selective mutism exactly and because they get glossed over people fall into these massive diagnostic and treatment traps
So our mission today is to decode those traps for you
We're gonna explore the precise triggers for these four conditions
Because you know missing the nuances here doesn't just mean failing a test. Yeah
it means failing to understand your own nervous system or
The behavior of someone you love okay, let's unpack this I want to start with the most concentrated form of anxiety possible
It's hyper focused. Yeah fear that is just lasered in on one single thing in the diagnostic manual geek notes
This is coded as f40.2, which I gotta say always sounds so weirdly robotic to me
Right assigning a literal barcode to human terror exactly. But what does that barcode actually mean?
Well, the clinical codes definitely strip away the emotion, but they they force us into precision
F40.2 is specific phobia. We don't really need to belabor the basic definition, right?
Everyone knows what a fear of heights or needles or you know dogs looks like sure the defining characteristic isn't just being afraid of those things
it's the act of avoidance that severely disrupts a person's life and
Crucially it has to persist for at least six months. Okay. I actually want to push back on that timeline a bit
Sure. Why is six months the magic number?
Like if I get bitten by a massive dog tomorrow and I spend the next four weeks completely terrified of dogs
Isn't that a phobia? My nervous system is definitely freaking out
Yeah, but your nervous system is functioning perfectly in that scenario. Wait, really? Absolutely. That's just a normal acute drama response
The six-month threshold is vital because it separates a temporary survival mechanism from a chronic entrenched cognitive distortion
Oh, I see like if a dog bites you staying away from dogs for a few if it's just good evolutionary sense
Yeah, that's just being smart. Yeah, exactly
But if half a year goes by and you are say
Refusing to walk in public parks or you turn down a promotion because the new office is near a doggy daycare
Well, the fear has metastasized Wow turning down a job. That's huge, right?
It's no longer just a memory of an event. The avoidance has become the self-perpetuating cycle
So the act of avoidance is really the engine of the phobia. It's not just you know, I dislike heights
It's I will absolutely not accept a job on the 10th floor Bingo
And that avoidance leads directly into keeks massive exam trap for this condition
Which honestly completely upends how most people think about treating anxiety
Yeah
This blew my mind when I read it if you were dealing with a specific phobia and the proposed treatment leads with a medication
It is wrong. See we are so culturally conditioned to view anxiety as a chemical imbalance that you know immediately requires a pill
Entirely, but keeks is totally adamant that the first line treatment here is exposure therapy
Medication is not the front line defense. Why is that because relying on a pill for a specific phobia misses the entire mechanism of the disorder a
Specific phobia isn't a systemic failure of your brain's chemistry. It's a localized learned
Association gotcha. The brain has basically incorrectly tagged one specific object as a lethal threat
So it's like having an overactive smoke alarm in just one room of your house say the kitchen
That's a great way to put it. You don't rewire the whole house's electricity, right? Which would be like taking
Generalized anxiety medication that suppresses your entire central nervous system, right? That's overkill
you just have to teach that specific alarm that a toaster isn't a fire and you do that by
Making some toast setting off the alarm and letting the system realize the house didn't burn down that analogy captures the neurological reality
Perfectly rewiring the whole house for a localized problem is incredibly inefficient when you have an f40.2 phobia
The anxiety is bound to the object. So the treatment has to directly address the relationship with that object
Exposure therapy does this by forcing the brain to experience the object without the catastrophic outcome, right?
A pill cannot teach your amygdala that a dog is safe
It only numbs the panic temporarily while the underlying false belief remains completely intact
And if you numb the panic but never actually do the exposure
The phobia just sits there in the dark doing push-ups waiting for the medication to wear off exactly
The avoidance is still running the show man
Okay
So if specific phobia is the smoke alarm going off in just one room keep moves us into our second category by widening the scope
What happens when the fear isn't attached to an object but to an entire environment, right?
Which brings us to agoraphobia coded as f40 point zero zero zero here
The environment itself becomes the threat
Yeah, and the clinical definition requires a marked fear of two or more specific situations
Keek lists the main five using public transit being in open spaces being in enclosed spaces
Standing in lines or crowds or being outside of the home alone
Okay, so you have to fear at least two of those if you only fear flying in airplanes
You're back in specific phobia territory, correct
But if you fear the airplane and the crowd eternal and the train ride to the airport
Now we are dealing with agoraphobia
Notice how the treatment protocol shifts here, too
Because the fear is broader and seeping into multiple environments. The first line treatment is still cognitive behavioral therapy
Specifically CBT with exposure, but it is frequently combined with an SSRI
Let's pause on SSRI because people throw that acronym around constantly. Yeah selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors basically standard
Depressants that are also used for anxiety, right?
Why are we bringing in the heavy chemical artillery here when we just said not to use it for specific phobias?
Well agoraphobia often creates a baseline level of panic so high that the patient cannot even engage in CBT
Oh, they're just too overwhelmed
Exactly. The SSRI helps lower that baseline physiological arousal
It turns the volume of the panic down from like a 10 to a 6 which makes the therapy possible, right?
It allows the cognitive behavioral therapy to actually penetrate
You really can't reason with a brain that thinks it's actively dying. Got it. The medication creates a window for the therapy to work
But let's get into the trap here because keep says this is where clinicians and everyday people make the biggest mistake
The agoraphobia versus social anxiety trap. What's fascinating here is the underlying cognitive mechanism
People look at someone avoiding a crowded shopping mall and instantly label it social anxiety because the behavior looks identical exactly
But the why driving the behavior is completely different. Let's go back to our bus from the beginning of the deep dive
I'm refusing to ride the bus to work because it's packed with people and I'm having panic attacks
Okay to anyone watching I'm just a person who can't handle public transit. Mm-hmm
How do I actually know which one I have you have to interrogate the internal monologue if you have agoraphobia?
Your terror centers around being trapped like physically stuck
Yeah, your brain is telling you if I have a panic attack on this packed bus. I can't get off
I am stuck between stops. No one can help me and I can't escape
The core themes are escape and help. Oh, wow. So it's like if my body betrays me right now
I am completely stranded contrast that with social anxiety on that exact same bus
A person with social anxiety is completely consumed by scrutiny judgment, right?
Their internal monologue is everyone on this bus staring at me. They're judging my clothes. They think I'm sweating weirdly
I am going to do something humiliating
So social anxiety is the terror of judgment and agoraphobia is the terror of entrapment
Is scrutiny versus escape and confusing those two is catastrophic for treatment. Imagine a therapist assuming you have social anxiety
So they spend six months working with you on, you know
Building self-esteem practicing public speaking and reframing other people's opinions that will do absolutely nothing if your actual underlying fear
Is having a medical emergency in a crowd with no exits. You're treating the wrong disease. Wow
You're basically treating a ghost
You're trying to fix a confidence problem when the person is actually dealing with a survival problem
Which is why kick hammers this distinction so hard
You must look past the superficial behavior of avoidance and uncover the actual cognitive fear
Okay, so we've moved from the fear of things to the fear of places
Now keek shifts the focus to how anxiety attaches itself to people right seeking safety in environments to seeking safety in
Specific individuals this is separation anxiety disorder coded f 93.0
Here's where it gets really interesting. It does when I hear separation anxiety
I immediately picture like a poddler sobbing while clinging to their parents leg at preschool drop off
That's the classic image. Yeah, but the manual update and kick's major warning here
Yeah, is that this is not just a childhood diagnosis anymore. No, not at all
Historically the field treated it as something you just outgrew
But the current framework recognizes it in adults
And the trap is ruling it out simply because the client has a mortgage and a 401k
But when cake uses the phrase developmentally inappropriate my mind goes to an adult literally acting like a toddler
You know throwing a tantrum when their spouse goes to work, right?
But it has to be more nuanced than that. What does developmentally inappropriate actually mean for a 35 year old?
Well, it's about the context of age changing the presentation of the anxiety even though the mechanism remains identical
It is completely developmentally appropriate for a three-year-old to experience intense distress when your mother leaves the room
That's a biological imperative for survival
Sure, but it is developmentally inappropriate for a 10 year old to refuse to go to a friend's house because they are paralyzed by the thought
That their parents will die in a car crash while they are away right and translating that to adults
It is developmentally appropriate for an adult to miss their partner when they travel or to worry occasionally about their health, of course
But it is developmentally inappropriate for an adult to suffer severe panic attacks
Be entirely incapable of functioning at work or constantly track their partner's location on their phone
Because the fear of sudden abandonment or loss is catastrophic
The tether between them has basically become a chokehold that invisible tether
It's like when the tether stretches even an inch the nervous system fires off a life or death alarm exactly
And thinking about this in grown adults. It makes me realize how easily we moralize this stuff
Oh constantly we label adults as needy clingy or having a toxic anxious
Attachment style we judge the behavior without realizing it might be a clinical diagnosable disorder
We do we tell them to just be more independent, which is completely useless
Yeah, telling someone with separation anxiety to be more independent is like telling someone with asthma to just breathe better
Oh, yeah, their nervous system is locked in a state of clinical alarm
That's why the first line treatment here is cbt
But often family-based or couples-based cbt i'll bring in the partner in right
You can't just treat the individual in a vacuum
The attachment figure is fundamentally part of the dynamic
You have to treat the system to help both parties slowly and safely stretch that tether without triggering a panic response
That makes so much sense. Okay. We have one final category from keek's notes
We've seen anxiety project onto objects environments and people
Now we look at what happens when anxiety completely shuts down outward communication the silencing effect
Yeah, how fear manifests by silencing us this is selective mutism f 94 points out
This is defined as a consistent failure to speak in expected specific social situations
The textbook example is the child who is completely mute at school, but a total chatterbox at home
And keynotes a very specific time frame role here, right?
It has to last for at least a month
But it cannot just be the first month of school that distinction is crucial
The first month of school is a massive environmental shock for children. A climate ization looks a lot like anxiety
So they're just getting used to things exactly
But if the absolute silence persists into october and november
We are no longer looking at normal developmental shyness. We are looking at a disorder. And what's the treatment?
The treatment protocol here is behavioral intervention often jump started with an ssri to lower that physiological arousal we talked about earlier
The trap cake highlights here is incredibly tragic. Yeah the adults in the room almost always misread the silence
They misread it as defiance or they misread it as a cognitive language disorder
If we connect this to the bigger picture of how schools operate the tragedy becomes obvious
You have a child sitting in class the teacher calls on them
The child stares straight ahead and says nothing, right?
The immediate adult assumption is usually behavioral like this kid is stubborn
They are refusing to participate to undermine my authority or they think something is wrong with their brain
Exactly. They assume a deficit. They don't understand the language or they have a severe speech delay, but kick is explicitly clear
The child absolutely can speak they have the vocabulary they speak fluently in safe environments
It is not a deficit of language and it is certainly not defiance. It is an extreme anxiety disorder
Let's dig into the how of that
How does anxiety literally stop a person from forming words?
Because if a parent or teacher thinks a child is just being stubborn their instinct is pressure
Always use your words speak up or you're losing recess
But if the child has selective beautism that pressure is gasoline on a fire, right?
It is actively destructive to understand how you have to look at the nervous system's threat response
Selective mutism is essentially a severe localized freeze response like fight flight or freeze exactly
When the brain perceives the school environment as a catastrophic threat it bypasses the higher order language centers entirely wait
It just cuts them off literally
The anxiety is so overwhelming that the vocal cords physically tense up. The child is paralyzed by fear
They aren't choosing to be silent any more than a deer caught in headlights is choosing to hold its ground
Wow, it is a biological survival mechanism overriding voluntary movement a freeze response
That completely changes the paradigm. Yeah, they aren't refusing to speak their body is holding them hostage
Which is why keek's ultimate directive for this condition is
Treat the anxiety not the refusal because the refusal isn't real, right?
Trying to force the child to speak just spikes their anxiety higher which deepens the freeze response
The behavioral interventions have to focus on making the environment feel safe
So you lower the terror first you lower the baseline terror until the child's nervous system realizes it isn't under attack
Allowing them to finally thaw out and use their voice treat the anxiety not the refusal. Yeah, that is such a profound takeaway
Because the refusal is just an illusion
It's just the tip of the iceberg of internal terror that concept really wraps around keek's entire lesson. It really does
Looking back at all four of these conditions. The overarching lesson here is that
treating anxiety
Requires an almost surgical level of precision. Absolutely. It's not just a blanket emotion
You can't just throw an ssri at a fear of needles
You have to do the grueling work of exposure therapy to rewire the brain's association, right?
You have to decouple agoraphobious fear of being trapped from social anxieties fear of judgment
Because building someone's self-esteem won't stop them from fearing they'll be stranded on a bus. Exactly
You have to look at an adult's crippling fear of being alone
And recognize that separation anxiety isn't just for kids
And you absolutely must look at a silent child and see terror not defiance because if you gloss over the mechanics you fall into the traps
You medicate a localized phobia or you punish a child for a biological freeze response
it all comes down to interrogating the why beneath the surface behavior
and
Before we wrap up. I want to leave you the listener with something to mull over something that builds on this especially the adult separation anxiety
We touched on yeah, we talked about that invisible tether between adults in our modern world
We are constantly tethered to our attachment figures. We have smartphones. We have read receipts on text messages
We have apps that track our partners locations on a map 24 7
We are never truly separated. Yeah, we've basically built an infrastructure of constant connection, right?
So here is the question
Could this technology be masking a massive underlying wave of separation anxiety disorder?
Oh, that's an interesting thought if your attachment figure is always just a text message away
And you can always see their little dot moving on a map
How would you even know if your fear of separation has become developmentally inappropriate, right?
Are we treating the anxiety or are we just accommodating it with technology exactly?
You might not even realize how entrenched the disorder is until your battery dies. It's a striking thought
When the digital tether snaps, we might find out our emotional tether is far more fragile than we realized
It definitely makes you look at your phone a little differently
We want to encourage you to keep questioning the behaviors you see in yourself and in the people around you
Don't settle for the superficial labels
dig into the cognitive machinery
Uncover the why and as cake says at the very end of her notes whatever challenge you're working through keep going you've got this
Thanks for joining us on this deep dive